all right I want to play a game with you
called team Nathan 14 oh no I know no oh
how could you choose I'm the judge I
can't be opinionated I can't pick a side
here because stressed he is so as you
know Elizabeth is caught in the middle
of this very complicated love triangle
both guys are great for different
reasons I want to know who you think is
the better choice for Elizabeth and why
I might be a little biased when I say
team Nathan I think can offer her the
security and strength I think Nathan
might need Elizabeth more than I think I
think I think team Blucas can offer her
a lot I think Nathan needs Elizabeth too
you know rich his life enriches life to
function to be a better person I am team
Lucas because I play Lucas yeah he
forces her to shake things up a little
bit he challenges her he's spontaneous
and exciting and just has I think a
little bit more Flair than Nathan does
Nathan is very square in terms of
working for the law and and his morals
you only live once so I don't have a
little fun Lucas I don't know if he's
necessarily the better suitor but I
think in terms of his character arc it's
been quite interesting he kind of came
into this town and we as as a as a town
and Hope Valley we didn't really know
how to approach him or what his
intentions were and and I think it sort
of taught all the characters not to
maybe maybe hold off on judgment a
little bit I got the pocket watch which
is always Oh looking dapper I'm gonna
say Nathan team Nathan okay and I'm
gonna say it's because of two things
number one I think the show was always
about a Mountie secondly his character
and her character kind of give each
other the gears a little bit more not in
a funny way but they're kind of they
bicker a little bit
kind of like that you like that kind of
do rich a little friction like he kind
of puts her in her place a little bit
and I don't think she's used to that and
kind of like that I miss I mean come on
he's sort of like sweet delicate and
also they're the artistic side oh look
at the guy yeah okay so you want to see
yeah I do something different this time
around exactly well if you're asking
rosemary who she votes for obviously she
would say Nathan cuz Lucas rubbed her
the wrong way at the very beginning when
he brought in that darn piano that plays
by itself and he didn't need rosemary to
sing he robbed her of an opportunity I
drove an opportunity so she's not a huge
fan of Lucas the entertainment will be
arriving by train shortly just wait
patiently like everyone else I would say
me personally I was always thinking
Lucas I was I was always thinking Lucas
and then I watched the season okay and I
saw that final moment when Nathan walks
out I will say that I love them both but
I think better suited for Elizabeth I
see her with Lucas I think they have
this connection over writing and
storytelling and that's something that's
vitally important for Elizabeth so I
just feel them they connect on a
different level than Nathan I'm on Team
Nathan why is that because Elizabeth
gets along so well with Allie and I
think that I would love to see a mother
figure for Allie
it could be loving loved her too so my
alleged family yeah yeah yeah
so I think I think that's that's the one
point over for major why I would be team
Nathan but what is Lucas is a close
second I'm on Team Lucas there's
something about him that I feel like
they just have that chemistry there's
something that's very unique and
mysterious about it I think after being
with Jack I think it would be nice to
see her with
I am team Lucas can't imagine her going
through the heartbreak of losing another
you know another mountain that's the
risk that's that's that's why I'm
leaning okay
let's race yes that's not a paul thing
that's a Carson thing that's a Carson
thing
what's the popping danger risk Oh okay
Paul says go Mountie oh yeah people
about T I'm gonna give you two boats I
have two I love that nathan has Ally I
love that there's a little family thing
there I also love that Lucas is a saloon
owner and charming I think it gives
Elizabeth mmm this is really yummy oh
that's so nice - right yeah it's like
all women kind of like that little
mystery and also that strength and
family if you had to give a point
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh 1% tipped advantage
who do you think has the competitive
edge the Mountie why is that got a red
Serge we know Elizabeth she kind of digs
red I just got to go with the surge and
the kid right now
I know Lucas has to step his game up
he's you know he's he's against the odds
here and he will you will not gonna be a
tiebreaker because I'm gonna tell you
both I'm team Nathan because I think he
really listens he has experience as a
parent he's gonna understand on a
personal level what it's like for
Elizabeth to be fearful about him being
a Mountie it's kind of a double-edged
sword there and he's very handsome and
funny and the list goes on I'm team
Lucas because also handsome and funny he
is a new energy for Elizabeth he's I
guess a little more bad-boy that's kind
of exciting he's still good with the kid
although less experienced it's very
generous my goodness he made her a
library did I mention
handsome and funny you mentioned that
yes okay she's got her work cut out for
her she's very sure
decisions are really hard for Aaron and
I think they might be really hard for
Elizabeth as well